faut-il dire adieu aux ticket de caisse
à compter de ce premier août 2023 vous
ne recevrez plus de tickets de caisse en
magasin si vous nous le demandez pas
expressément repoussé par deux fois par
le gouvernement à cause de l'inflation
qui chamboule les contes des Français
cette mesure est absolument
incontournable sur le plan écologique et
steam Francis palomby président de la
Confédération des commerçants de France
en raison de tous ces tickets de caisse
qui finissent à la poubelle concrètement
chaque année ces 12,5 milliards de
tickets de caisse qui sont imprimés en
France soit 25 millions d'arbres coupés
et 18 milliards de litres d'eau consommé
selon Bercy ces bouts de papier qu'on a
l'habitude de manipuler ne sont pas sans
risque pour la santé il contient en
effet du bisphénol A une substance
chimique qui perturbe le fonctionnement
hormonal et accroît les risques de
cancer et d'infertilité SMS email
application ou QR code tous les moyens
sont bons pour remplacer le ticket
imprimé mais si la plupart des
commerçants ont déjà intégré cette
mesure notamment dans la grande
distribution ou l'impression de ticket
est optionnel l'adaptation reste
difficile pour des petits commerçants je
n'ai pas du tout réfléchi à la question
ça va être le travail de explique
Camille gérant d'une boutique
indépendante de prêt-à-porter à Paris la
question des retours l'inquiète j'ai une
cliente qui est revenue pour un retour
et n'avait pas de ticket me disant qu'on
lui en avait pas donné j'ai été obligé
de refuser le retour j'ai absolument
besoin du ticket pour pouvoir faire un
échange jugé trop compliqué oui utile
par beaucoup de petits commerces les
alternatives numériques sont souvent
délaissés laissant deux options aux
consommateur obtenir un ticket imprimé
ou sans passer c'est le cas de Mathieu
restaurateur de la rue Montorgueil à
Paris les clients doivent donner leur
mail on peut se tromper d'orthographe
cela prend plus de temps alors on s'en
passe de leur côté plusieurs
associations de consommateurs dont l'UFC
Que Choisir et familles rural ont
rappelé que le ticket de caisse est un
outil de gestion du budget familial de
nombreux ménages alors que l'inflation
alimentaire était de 12,6% en juillet
après avoir atteint les 13,7% en juin
selon l'Insee la numérisation du ticket
de caisse soulève également des craintes
autour du respect des données
personnelles la Commission nationale de
l'information et des libertés rappelle
notamment la nécessité du cons au moment
de recueillir les données personnelles
du client si le commerçant décide de
proposer l'envoi dématérialisée du
ticket les solutions à privilégier
devront chercher à minimiser autant que
possible la collecte de données
personnelles voire à l'éviter le
gendarme du numérique met aussi en garde
contre les risques que celle-ci soit
réutilisées à des fins de prospection
commerciale notamment dans les petites
structures pas de souci pour le grand
supermarché qui fait remplir son fichier
client à la main ils ont les moyens de
mettre en place ce genre de choses et
une armada de juristes qui les conseille
mais un commerçant indépendant ne pourra
pas se le permettre
[Musique]